[Musique]
même la princesse anne de belgique l'an
passé n'avait eu droit à pareil accueil
le président salengro en personne le
chef d'état de la présipauté de groland
la presse internationale et bien sur
france 3 poitou charentes ne pouvait
rater cet événement mondial qui méritait
bien déroulé le tapis rouge très rouge
enroulait m'a accueilli de nombreux
chefs d'état et têtes couronnées
jamais jamais jusqu'à présent un
président de votre prestige un pays de
ville une ville un pays un pays une
ville une ville un pays ce témoin le
phrasé coincé dans mon appareil dentaire
c'est avec émotion que notre président
beauté est préférable pour la première
fois reconnu par une instance
internationale
et croyez moi monsieur le maire nous
saurons nous en souvenir lors
d'éventuels conflits
vous pourrez compter sur nous un
partenariat est donc scellé aujourd'hui
bien jumelage étrenné par une exposition
celle du grand maître fayot regardez
une couleur qu'elle couche excusez moi
hollande invité d'honneur du festival
2004 évidemment les plus hautes
personnalités politiques régionales ne
pouvait pas ne pas être là surtout en
cette période électorale le président
salengro lui s'épargne toutes ces
petites tracasseries démocratique il est
le seul à avoir le droit de vote à
groland
[Musique]